this this event is sponsored by Public
Square if you guys want to help win the
culture war and support businesses that
support our values download the Public
Square app check out businesses in your
area I really do mean it but I want to
talk about the national debt for a
minute um 33 trillion counting we just
printed 250 billion in one day which is
what is that a national record alltime
record it looks like the interest is
compounding such that it's impossible to
pay back that the only way to pay back
that 33 trillion is to borrow 33
trillion at interest and then we'll keep
we can pay back the balance but then we
owe interest on the 33 trillion we just
borrowed and there it's it's a never-
ending Ponzi scheme so is there any
value to defaulting on the interest that
we owe the Federal
Reserve or ending the FED one step at a
time but yeah I like that too well and
and honestly the FED is how we've got in
the position because like you know
remember Grover NorQuest who I think
right now is actually paying for
advertisements attacking me he set up
this Paradigm that well if we just stop
tax increases then we'll be able to
starve the Beast of money and while you
got politicians to agree to that in in
large scale you still have fed policy
that continues to uh pick winners and
losers across the board I worry about
the 8 trillion that is about ready to
have to be refinanced at higher interest
rates we we have eight trillion of that
debt that you know is at very very low
interest rates infantes family low and
now when you're refinancing that now
that's going to affect APR that's going
to affect every auto loan every home
loan and the cost of money is going to
is going to go through the roof uh I
don't know that defaulting on the
interest makes that problem any better
uh I could see a number of circumstances
where it could make it worse by the way
you know who is feeling that the most
right now so here's a a basic math for
you a half a million dollar loan today
versus a year ago if you get a half a
million dollar loan the average person
let's just say at 8% today you got a 720
credit score it's not a great score but
you got a decent credit score 720
half a million at 8% 30 years at 720
credit score your mortgage payment is$
3669 roughly
$3,700 18 months ago that half a million
dollar loan at 3% 720 credit score 30
years ready $2,100 wow from $2,100 to
$3,700 but check this out the bank is
going to now see at what income you need
to make to be able to afford that house
so you got to take that 21 uh uh 70 and
you got to divide it by 36% just do that
on your math on your calculator come up
with $5,500 a month which means the
bank's going to expect you to make
roughly 70 grand a year to qualify for
this half a million dollar loan at 3%
interest rate to be$ 2170 at the 8%
which is $3,700 divided by 36% you would
need to make
$122,000 a year in 18 months from 70
grand year to 122 so as much as you and
I are talking about national debt and
I'm very worried about the national debt
the average person sitting there saying
how the hell am I supposed to afford to
buy a house today my income's not going
up everyone's going on strikes right now
Union is dividing employe against
employees people are not starting small
businesses like they did before you're
talking about interest rate on the $8
trillion you know how scary that is when
you go through the new rate that is
absolutely catastrophic we sold the
company uh last year July 1st of 20 uh
uh 22 right before where money got
expensive if we would sold the company a
month later versus a month prior we
would have made 20% 10% Less on the sale
of the company because money kept
getting more and more and more and more
expensive so the buyers cannot go buy
everything that's cheap today commercial
property I'm sure you saw this we work
in 2017 you guys heard of Wei work
everybody here knows Wei workor you know
what Wei work was worth in 2017 when
SoftBank gave him $8.9 billion it was
valued at $47 billion you know what
happened to we work this week they could
not make a $95 million payment they went
into default a $47 billion and what does
that tell you that's commercial real
estate so the lowest we haven't yet seen
the 2008 default on mortgage payments
that we did which hit the real estate
market we haven't experienced that but
you're seeing it in commercial real
estate they're not making a payments
today and it's pretty ugly and you're
seeing it in the subprime segment of car
payments so people who got subprime
loans these are lower level credit
scores 600 580s that they got those kind
of uh loans they're defaulting on their
car payments right now so we're seeing
it in different pockets and then
eventually these people that don't want
to sell their homes because they're
sitting on a 3% interest all of a sudden
if they start saying babe we're running
out of money babe we could we got to
sell this house we got to sell this out
what are we going to do with this once
that happens next you're going to feel
it so there's some economists today that
are saying everything's going to be all
right yeah you know it's just going to
be a soft Landing all this kind of
they're giving you but there's
some guys behind closed doors that are
like listen man this Michael bu guy is
worried about the S&P 500 no one knows
what's really going to be happening
right now they're seeing what's going on
with unemployment in the job market so
they they're going to bump the rates
again another quarter basis point in the
next month or two they do that the next
30 60 90 days no one's thinking 33
trillion people are thinking how the
hell am I going to pay my payment and
how I going to increase my income it's
it's going to be an interesting next 3
six months for the average voter well
maybe if uh if the average person can't
afford to buy a house anymore there's
some kind of lowincome personal
occupancy device pod for short they
could buy instead and then um if the
food be comes too expensive there's
always bugs so I guess my point is
perhaps it's on purpose they there we
know that there's been these big
Financial interests buying up
residential homes converting them into
rentals now with what you're describing
it's becoming more and more difficult to
be an independent human being especially
with a family so one of uh one segment I
recorded on is AOC wants to raise income
the income tax on New York residents who
are in the top 5% of income earners the
top five % is not the same as the top 1%
it's a it's it's a huge leap and there
was an organization that said basically
what you're saying is anybody who makes
$250,000 a year or more in New York City
now $250,000 a year is a lot of money
but in New York City the you're talking
about a man and woman who who are both
working full-time hard enough to have a
family and they're each making like 127
and they're living in Jersey and they're
or or right and living in Jersey a
one-bedroom apartment is four grand in
New York city so you're talking about a
third to to uh uh you know about a third
or a little bit more than a third of
your income every month in just rent
don't forget food now what if you want
to have kids as as they increase taxes
and increase the pressure and make it
harder to buy now you're talking do you
want to own you want that's going to be
impossible yeah and it's going to be
it's going to be five or sixk a month to
even own anything the reality is you you
need you need a three or four bedroom if
you're a mar a young married couple
trying to have a family but now both
parents are working full-time they have
no choice but to put their kids in
institutionalized learning facilities
the reality is with with everything
you're talking about it's not just about
the family saying hey we're running out
of money we got to sell the house it's
about Millennials saying I've never had
a house I can't even get married I can't
have kids I can't afford it at all the
end result being whether you think it's
intentional or not people are going to
live in pods and they're going to eat
bugs because they don't have the money
and no wealth is being built because
we've been converted into a generation
of renters and you look at how the
Boomers built wealth it was it was
typically through home ownership it's
the number one way the last generation
built wealth but and I think it goes
back to the Point culturally about how
we think about family formation and when
your starter home is your forever home
because you can't leave it because you
can't get out of that low interest rate
uh for the for the simple math that that
Patrick was describing it changes the
way you think about your prospects to be
able to to to grow and and be able to be
more as a family if you're lucky enough
to get a house o over black rock that
has very low interest rates compared to
your 8% interest rates I think there's a
reason Thomas Jefferson warned that
banking in institutions are more
dangerous to our liberties than standing
armies I think what we're seeing right
now with the US Federal Reserve what we
saw with the secret bailouts that they
did during coid that they did in 2008
are so incredibly incredulous we're
talking about trillions of dollars that
passed through the banking system to all
these institutions blackre State Street
JP Morgan and Chase that by the way just
settled the Jeffrey Epstein lawsuit
where they were caught being complicit
in aiding the raping of thousands of
children for over 30 plus years so when
when we're looking at these big Banks
when we're looking at the Federal
Reserve how do we solve this because I
really really do believe that this is
being done on purpose in order to sew
chaos and civil unrest I think they're
going to bleed us dry and then they're
going to set us loose and then chaos is
going happen why why would they do that
because it's Swiss oh sorry to interrupt
why would they do that though think
about why they would do that problem
reaction solution so I think they are
motivated towards creating chaos why did
Dr fouchy along with Peter daak and Echo
Health Alliance work on making
essentially a bioweapon why did the bank
banksters in 2008 have Banker bailouts
while of course having the taxpayer for
for it why is the system so corrupted
why did the FBI for 30 plus years look
the other way and ignored victims of
Jeffrey Epstein that came to them the
system is rotten and it thrives off of
misery and I think it's going to create
more misery through the banking system
very for me I think there's two ways uh
uh yeah you can make some noise for him
so I'm at a church and my pastor gets up
and he says this is an LA Pastor Dudley
Rutherford he says you know you know
there's this guy in the church he's not
getting baptized every week he's not
getting baptized and the Pastor said
well God loves you God loves you God
loves you this is a moment if you
dealing with something you want to walk
up this is the time to do it it's like
nobody was walking he say one day
another Pastor tells me says why don't
you start selling hell he says what do
you mean said just try selling Kell so I
don't understand tell them what happens
if they don't give their life to Christ
so the pastor gets up on stage and says
if you don't give your life to Christ
here's what hell's going to look like
and know you know it goes into this me
about oh my God hundreds of people count
I want to be a Christian I want to get
baptized right so selling hell works
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time